en el movistar team a anunció un
refuerzo de lujo hablamos de nada menos
y nada más que la neerlandesa nemec
tablet en la vigente campeona del mundo
y considerada la mejor que la lista del
planeta en los últimos años completó en
tiene 37 años llega desde el milton
scott firma hasta el 2022 con el
conjunto español que asegura que con
esta contratación quieren reforzar su
apuesta en el world tour femenino en el
palmarés del bable tan figuran dos la
course by le tour de france 2 giros rosa
una vieja basto liga y un tour de
flandes entre otros este fin de semana
ha nacido en países bajos terminó quinta
en la cox applet en ser ahora compañera
de la colombiana paula patiño en las
filas del movistar y por cierto de lan
hernández estuvo precisamente el año
pasado de entrenamiento aquí en tierras
cafeteras